hola en este vídeo quiero hablarte un
poco acerca de este largo viaje que
hemos hecho a través de la química hasta
ahora hemos tocado el tema de bueno
interacciones entre moléculas sobre
moléculas de metal cómo se atraen entre
sí por este mar de electrones y bueno
también hablamos sobre las moléculas del
agua pero creo que es bueno tener una
discusión general sobre los diferentes
tipos de interacciones moleculares y qué
significan para los puntos de ebullición
y los puntos de fusión de una substancia
así que voy a empezar con el más débil y
para eso
voy a dibujar aquí un montón de neón
pero antes déjame ponerte aquí la tabla
periódica para que veas por qué me estoy
tomando en león si te das cuenta el neón
está justo aquí es decir es un gas noble
y bueno es que los gases nobles son
bastante felices su órbita el externo
está lleno por lo tanto un amd si por
aquí dibujo un neón y déjame tomar este
color para hablar de neón imagínate que
por aquí tengo un neón ok y bueno este
neón tiene ocho
y aquí tengo todos ok aquí tengo otros
dos ok
aquí tengo otros dos y bueno por aquí
tengo otros dos de lujo aquí tengo un
neón y es más déjame poner por aquí a
otro neón este neón está bastante feliz
porque tiene a todos sus electrones
tenemos aquí cada uno de estos ocho de
trones y bueno este neón está bastante
feliz está completamente satisfecho
consigo mismo si estos electrones están
distribuidos uniformemente alrededor de
estos átomos entonces estos son átomos
completamente neutros estos átomos no
quieren unirse entre sí o hacia
cualquier cosa así que solamente
deberían flotar alrededor y no hay razón
alguna para que se sientan o no atraídos
los unos con nosotros pero resulta que
el neón tiene un estado líquido si
consigues enfriarlo lo suficiente y por
el hecho de que tiene un estado líquido
significa que debe de haber alguna
fuerza tarde o temprano que está
haciendo que estos dos átomos de neón
de alguna manera bueno pues se sientan
atraídos am déjame ponerlo así se
sienten atraídos el uno con el otro
entonces no hay una gran cantidad de
fuerza que los atraiga y bueno esto es
porque va a ser un gas en la mayoría de
las temperaturas pero si bajas mucho la
temperatura puedes obtener una fuerza
muy débil que empieza a conectar o hace
que las moléculas de neón quieran
acercarse las unas a las otras y estas
fuerzas reales de lo que hemos hablado
antes realmente estos electrones no
tienen una órbita uniforme o fija
alrededor de estos átomos todo esto es
probabilístico si imaginamos que los
puntos de los electrones de valencia del
neón son una nube de probabilidad y
bueno no sólo eso si además recordamos
que el neón y déjame bajar un poco tiene
la configuración electrónica de 1s 2 y
después por acá su órbita exterior de 2
s 2 y por acá 2 p 6 bueno esto es cierto
entonces am si subimos ahora la pantalla
y queremos dibujar de nuevo a nuestro
neón bueno este el neón se va a ver más
o menos así tenemos a un átomo de neón
aquí y después tenemos un caparazón más
o menos como éste qué es
son 2 s y eso no está dentro de esto
verdad y también tenemos los orbitales p
que pueden o se ven más o menos así
tendría una cultura a otra como por acá
otra como por acá sólo estoy dibujando
la distribución de probabilidad no se
tratan de dibujar un conejo o jose aquí
tengo otro neon and bueno pues aquí
tenemos también su caparazón 12s y los
orbitales p algo más o menos así este
saber más o menos así a esta ciudad
hermanos menos así para que ticas que no
es un conejo voy a poner esta por acá y
esta también por acá ok lo importante de
todo esto lo que quiero que veas es que
entiendas el punto y bueno si quieres
ver los vídeos sobre configuración
electrónica vas a tener más ideas acerca
de estas distribuciones de probabilidad
y lo que quiero que entiendas es que los
electrones podrían estar en cualquier
lugar puede haber un momento en que
todos los electrones estén no sé por
esta parte de aquí o podrían estar por
esta parte de aquí qué sé yo si piensas
un poco sobre esto de todas las posibles
configuraciones vamos a decir que
tenemos estos dos átomos de neón y en
red
hay una probabilidad muy baja de que
vayan a ser distribuidos de una manera
uniforme por completo es decir que los
átomos están distribuidos de una manera
uniforme
casi no hay probabilidad de eso hay
muchos escenarios donde la distribución
de los electrones es un poco irregular
en uno u otro átomos de neón por ejemplo
si aquí tengo un átomo de neón este de
aquí y digo que sus 8 electrones vamos a
tener los de la siguiente manera tenemos
8 electorales de valencia 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
y por acá el otro entonces aquí se
parece este átomo de neón este tiene
temporalmente una ligera carga en esta
dirección cierto tiene una ligera carga
negativa por aquí y una ligera carga
positiva por aquí ok y ahora imagínate
que del mismo modo tengo otro neón por
equipo que voy a poner a este neón tiene
sus 8 electrones pero de esta forma
tiene uno no sé 2 a 3
es 45 16 7 y georges por acá y bueno si
te das cuenta este átomo de neón que
acabo de poner aquí tiene más carga
negativa a este lado que de este lado
así que si ahora quiero cambiar de color
fíjate que por un cierto momento si este
átomo tiene una ligera carga positiva de
este lado y aquí negativa y esté por
aquí positiva y por aquí negativa puede
llegar a admitirse una fuerza de
atracción por un pequeño momento de este
átomo con este átomo y después de este
pequeño momento desaparecerá porque los
electrones se reconfiguran pero lo
importante es darse cuenta que casi en
ningún momento los electrones del neón
van a ser distribuidos por completo esto
siempre va a ser una distribución
irregular siempre habrá un poco de carga
extra en un nuevo otro lado de un átomo
lo cual nos permitirá traer las cargas
supuestas de otras moléculas
similarmente desequilibradas
esta es una fuerza muy pero muy pero muy
débil que por cierto se le llama como la
fuerza de dispersión del london antes de
ponerlo así aquí esta fuerza se le
conoce como la fuerza de dispersión
dispersión ok de london d
london los dos y de hecho curiosamente
fritz london no era británico creo que
era un alemán americano en fin la fuerza
de dispersión de london es la más débil
de las fuerzas de van der waals antes de
ponerlo así
de valls
ok que seguramente estoy pronunciando
mal y bueno las fuerzas de van der vaart
son las clases de fuerza de todo lo
inter molecular y en este caso las
moléculas serían estos átomos de neón es
una molécula compuesta por un solo átomo
las fuerzas de van der vaart son una
clase de todas las fuerzas inter
moleculares que no son enlaces
covalentes y que no son enlaces iónicos
como los que tenemos las sales y
hablaremos de eso en un momento y de
hecho la más débil de todas ellas es la
fuerza de dispersión de london y esto es
porque el león es un gas noble de hecho
todos los gases nobles y para eso han
déjame bajar de nuevo para que los veas
aquí todos los gases nobles estos que
tenemos aquí ya es más déjame ponerlos
con este color todos estos que son mis
gases nobles experimentan este tipo de
fuerza de dispersión de london todos
estos de aquí que por cierto recuerda
que es la más débil de todas estas
fuerzas inter moleculares y es por esto
que se necesita muy poca energía para
poner
en un estado gaseoso así que a muy pero
muy baja temperatura los gases nobles
todos estos de aquí se convertirán al
estado gaseoso y de hecho es justo por
eso que se llaman gases nobles y bueno
estos gases nobles son los más propensos
en comportarse como gases ideales porque
tienen una pequeña pero muy pequeña
atracción entre ellos ahora que pasan en
una situación en donde vemos las que
tienen mayor atracción o que son un poco
más polares
imagínate que ahora tengo el cloruro de
hidrógeno y el hidrógeno y déjeme
tomarlo con este color aquí tengo al
hidrógeno esto de aquí y bueno el
nitrógeno es algo raro porque es un poco
ambivalente sobre si mantiene o no sus
electrones el cloro siempre quiere
mantener sus electrones
de hecho el cloro el cloro están más o
menos por aquí aquí tengo el cloro y
bueno este cloro es bastante electro
negativo aunque bueno ojo es menos
electro negativo que estos tres que
tengo aquí esto es de aquí de hecho son
mucho más electro negativos que lo que
digamos que estos son una especie de
super ultra elementos que acaparan
electrones es decir el nitrógeno el
oxígeno y el flúor pero de todos modos
el cloro es bastante electro negativo
así que si ahora pensamos en el cloruro
de hidrógeno y bueno se va a ver más o
menos así imagínate que yo por aquí a mí
déjame ponerlo con este color tengo al
cloro ok y bueno tienes 7am átomos de
valencia 1 2 3 4 5 6 y este átomo que
está compartiendo con el hidrógeno que
lo voy a poner con este color y bueno
pues aquí tengo el hidrógeno y el
hidrógeno va a compartir este electrón
con el cloro y bueno como el cloro es
más electro negativo que el hidrógeno
entonces estos electrones van a pasar
mucho más tiempo aquí de lo que van a
terminar pasando de este lado y eso hace
que en este lado del cloro haya una
carga parcial negativa negativa de este
lado mientras que de este otro lado del
hidrógeno va a haber una carga parcial
positiva
positiva son cargas parciales aquí
tenemos una carga parcial negativa de
este lado del cloro y aquí tenemos una
carga parcial positiva de este lado del
hidrógeno de hecho esto es muy análogo
para los enlaces de hidrógeno los
enlaces de hidrógeno son una clase de
bueno de este tipo de enlaces el cual se
llama un enlace de polo o una
interacción dipolo dipolo así que
imagínate que ahora todos tomamos a otra
molécula antes de ponerlo con esto ok
voy a atrapar esta molécula la voy a
copiar y la voy a pegar ok y ahora
imagínate que tenemos otra molécula de
cloruro de hidrógeno como por aquí
fíjate que lo que va a pasar es lo
siguiente vamos a tener una atracción am
que se va a ver más o menos con este
color no voy a poner voy a consentir una
atracción entre estas dos moléculas del
cloruro de hidrógeno y esto es porque el
lado positivo o mejor dicho el polo
positivo de esta molécula o de este tipo
lo es el lado del hidrógeno porque los
electrones en cierto modo se han alejado
y entonces esta parte de aquí se va a
sentir atraída por el lado del cloro
en este caso por el lado del cloro de
esta otra molécula y es por esta razón
que las fuerzas de van der vaart son una
interacción dipolo dipolo y es mucho más
fuerte que bueno en esta fuerza que
teníamos acá arriba la fuerza de
dispersión del hondo y sólo para ser
claro la fuerza de dispersión de london
ocurre en todas las interacciones
moleculares eso es lo que es muy débil
cuando las comparas con casi cualquier
otra cosa como en este caso es decir
sólo es relevante cuando hablamos de
cosas como gases nobles incluso aquí
también son fuerzas de dispersión del
london cuando la distribución de
electrones a esto de aquí sólo pasa para
ir de una u otra forma y esto solamente
es por un instante pequeño de tiempo
pero eso sí si nosotros pensamos en la
interacción dipolo dipolo que es la que
tenemos justo aquí ésta es mucho más
fuerte debido a que es más fuerte el
cloruro de hidrógeno va a tomar más
energía lo que va a hacer que esté mucho
más tiempo en estado líquido o que sea
más difícil entrar en el estado gaseoso
y ahora bien si nos fijamos en uno de
los átomos mucho
electro negativos como estos que tenemos
aquí el nitrógeno el oxígeno o el flúor
algunos de estos y supongamos que
queremos ser no sé se me ocurre a déjame
sobre un poco en la pantalla sumamos un
poco de pantalla porque vamos a hablar
acerca de la interacción entre el flúor
y el hidrógeno
imagínate que por aquí tenemos el
fluoruro de hidrógeno y déjenme ponerlos
con este color se me ocurre voy a tener
aquí h y aquí efe ok por aquí a otra h y
aquí otra efe ok y aquí ya no sé se me
ocurre poner otra h ok y otra efe ok por
acá am por acá también voy a poner otra
h y otra
efe fluoruro de hidrógeno tenemos un
montón de estos alrededor de este lugar
y bueno es que el flúor es ultra electro
negativo es uno de los tres átomos más
electro negativos en la tabla periódica
recuerda son estos de aquí a estos de
aquí el nitrógeno el oxígeno y el flúor
entonces ahora que tenemos este ponche
de moléculas justo aquí lo que va a
pasar es que se va a dar un caso muy
fuerte de la interacción dipolo dipolo
donde aquí todos los electrones y déjame
ponerlo con este color todos los
electrones van a ser atraídos por el
lado del flúor por este lado por este
lado por este lado lo que va a hacer que
tenga una carga parcial negativa
ok una carga parcial negativa una carga
parcial negativa una carga parcial
negativa mientras que del lado del
hidrógeno vamos a tener una carga
parcial positiva carga parcial positiva
en carga parcial positiva
ok este es un signo de más carga parcial
positiva ok
carga parcial positiva y es que esto me
va a dar una interacción entre las
moléculas muy fuertes ahora imagínate
que nosotros nos fijamos en la
interacción dipolo dipolo pero como es
una interacción dipolo dipolo entonces
estos dos van a interactuar y no sé se
me ocurre que este con este también va a
haber una interacción y es justo esto es
lo que se conoce como el
enlace de hidrógeno porque estamos
tratando con hidrógenos el hidrógeno y
un átomo muy electro negativo donde el
átomo electro negativo atrae casi todos
los electrones del hidrógeno y entonces
el hidrógeno está sentado ahí con un
solo protón lo que lo hace ser bastante
positivo y esto hace que sea realmente
atraído por el lado negativo de esta
otra molécula el lado positivo con el
lado negativo pero bueno lo importante
es que todas estas son fuerzas de van
der vaart en todas estas y de hecho
nosotros sabemos que son estas tres la
más débil bueno es la fuerza de
dispersión de london ok después nosotros
nos fijamos en la interacción entre una
molécula con un átomo más electro
negativo y esto empieza a hacer un
dipolo donde tienes un lado donde la
molécula se convierte en polar y
entonces de un lado tenemos carga
positiva del otro lado tenemos carga
negativo y cuando la ponemos con otra
molécula se da la interacción de polo
dipolo y bueno también tenemos una
tercera que es esta de aquí arriba esta
de aquí arriba nos da un enlace
aún más fuerte que es el enlace de
hidrógeno porque tenemos un átomo super
electro negativo que está quitando
esencialmente el electrón del hidrógeno
o clasificándolo este electrón se sigue
compartiendo pero está casi todo de este
lado de la molécula y bueno ya que
incluso este enlace es el más fuerte de
los tres tendrá incluso un punto de
ebullición más alto así que antes de
nombrarlos por aquí si yo tengo la
fuerza de dispersión del london déjeme
ponerlo así london ok después vimos la
dipolo ok dipolo ok y después vimos el
enlace de hidrógeno antes de ponerlo así
y drone que no ok
estas tres son fuerzas de van der waals
pero por las fuerzas de los enlaces
inter moleculares se hacen más fuerte lo
que me da que el enlace de hidrógeno
tenga un punto de ebullición más alto
que los enlaces polares y éstos a su vez
tengan un punto de ebullición más alto
que las fuerzas de dispersión de london
este punto de ebullición sube porque se
necesita más y más energía para separar
estas moléculas las unas de las otras
así que creo que esto es un buen estudio
de los diferentes tipos de interacciones
inter moleculares que no son
necesariamente covalentes o iónicas en
el siguiente vídeo hablaré sobre algunos
tipos de estructuras johnny cash y
covalentes y hablaré sobre cómo se
pueden formar y cómo esto puede afectar
a los diferentes puntos de ebullición